attention
daniel lavoie cet entretien a lieu le
jour de votre fait donc tout d'abord
joyeux anniversaire si vous êtes né à
250 km de saint boniface à donnery oui
qu'est ce que justement le manitoba vous
est donné pour que vous puissiez devenir
un artiste accompli un coot
indirectement probablement tout parce
que
j'ai à peu près
noan informative sont quand même les
années les premières années je dirais
que à partir du moment où j'arrivais au
québec je pense que j'avais sensiblement
le bagage que j'ai utilisée après pour
le restant de ma vie
j'ai quitté
mon arbre
on est venu couper vous êtes un grand
timide ça produit est facile cette
arrivée au québec là où vous devez
rencontrer des gens tentés de faire
votre place dans la chanson où il y en
avait déjà beaucoup d'artistes
francophones mais effectivement un grand
timide parce que tous les matchs où les
francs comme un double cd grand timide
je vous avais vécu au manitoba vous
savez la plupart des franco manitobain
au 1 si vous avez lu la détresse et
l'enchantement
vous savez que on a tous un petit
complexe d'infériorité ont fait pas trop
de bruit on dérange pas on fait notre
vie et puis et puis ça fait partie de
moi j'ai grandi comme ça j'ai grandi
dans un pays dans un village où il y
avait autant d'anglophones quatre
francophones donc on apprend à être à
être plus tranquille donc gdgt timide
sans vraiment l'être je me suis rendu
compte avec les années que je n'étais
pas aussi timide que que que je pensais
lettre
[Musique]
comme m
parmi vos grands succès il y a il sème
jours de plaine mais ma préférée si je
voudrais voir new york vous savez que
c'est une grande chanson lors du mixage
final de cette chaude j'ai jamais su
qu'une chanson à des marchés c'est à une
époque où je je je cherchais beaucoup
jeu j'osais des désaccords que qui était
un petit peu hors norme qui était si
vous écoutez le refrain cool moi pour
moi au fond de toi c'était bobic chose
qu'on osait faire en chansons pop à
l'époque
c'est certain même quand j'ai fait ils
s'aiment j'avais pas envie de mettre
cette chanson sur l'album pour moi c'est
une chanson trop intimes je sentais pas
que c'était absolument pas y'a pas de
refrain avait rien et finalement c'est
devenu la chanson la plus connue de mon
répertoire dont j'avoue que pour new
york je ne savais pas du tout
je n'ai jamais vu
[Musique]
depuis 1998 vous avez chanté partout
dans le monde dans la comédie musicale
notre dame de paris vous avez participé
à 1000 représentations comment
pourriez-vous nous décrire cette
expérience au début c'était un petit peu
un délire parce que notre dame était de
big big big big big sa vie vraie comme
ça c'était un peu difficile et à la
limite de l'insupportable
mais maintenant c'est devenu beaucoup
plus cool et j'avoue que j'y prends
énormément plaisir
[Musique]
car ça démarre et d'autres heures de
paye c'était complètement fou vous étiez
des superstars on était les beatles
c'était vraiment de la folie à l'époque
je me souviens avec 1000 personnes qui
nous attendait à la fin des spectacles
et fallait courir beau pot pour les
échappés leur échapper c'était vraiment
un délire absolument incroyable elle met
anecdote que je préfère de cette époque
là c'est que quand on arrivait au
théâtre le soir parce que tous les soirs
au palais des congrès justement et y
avait toujours cinq ou six cents
personnes qui attendaient pour nous
accrocher pour avoir des autographes des
photos et caetera et il fallait passer à
travers vous n'avez pas le temps
d'attendre lui faire tout ça donc on
avait trouvé le système qui fonctionnait
depuis merveilleusement dont certaines
au téléphone et on faisait comme si on
parlait tél 06 16 heures oui oui bonsoir
oui oui c'est les pieds on en arriver là
faisant famille rentrent à nos
téléphones et les gens nous laisser
passer comme ce touriste et on le fait
ce soir après soir ç'a marché doute
daniel lavoie il ya cette nouvelle
compilation mais à quand un nouvel album
avec des chansons écoutées en train de
se faire en ce moment j'ai écrit un
album dans le ce que j'appellerais le
style de jimmy broyeuse que j'ai connu
avec mon nom quand j'étais au manitoba
en nombre écouter jimmie rodgers de
vieux chanteur de country et j'écris
dizaine de chansons à la jim rogers à
régler
[Musique]
m
j'ai demandé à mon fils joseph qui fait
de la musique qui
maîtrise très bien la matière musicale
de réaliser l'album donc je suis en
train de réaliser un album de folk sonne
anglais avec une guitare acoustique et
des cuivres qui va peut-être sortir un
jour peut-être
cela poète est fait pour sortir mais on
sait jamais j'ai vraiment hâte
d'entendre à verser un bon groupe et
nous daniel lavoie merci à vous
[Musique]
charge à te donne dans matin